c'est une gourde et ça vient d'où c'est
de la c'est un fruit de la famille de la
famille des courges et qu'est-ce qui lui
est arrivé il
a David est coup gourdonnier il
travaille avec des calebasses donc et
propose à l'occasion de ces journées du
potager de partager sa passion l'intérêt
c'est de redécouvrir en fait un légume
ancien qui depuis 10 ans je remets au
bout du jour pour faire découvrir aux
enfants que dans la nature vous avez des
fruits et des légumes qui ont une autre
fonction que celle d'être mangé c'est
gourditos des légumes que l'on n'est pas
obligé de manger juste là pour faire
beau l'idée plaî aux enfants comme aux
parents je voulais faire
un une princesse pour ma sœur on a
d'abord peint du coup la petite coloquin
d'une couleur on a choisi un peu le
thème donc princesse évidemment et puis
après on a rajouté les yeux les bras et
pour finir la décoration j'aime bien la
peinture et puis je trouve ça sympa de
faire des
bonhommes en en fruits c'est sympa tu
sais où tu vas la mettre la princesse
ensuite bah dans la chambre et qui dit
jardin d' herbe fraîche aussi dans cette
atelier excite les infusions en avant la
préparation et la dégustation de sirop
et de bonbons et la formule 100%
naturelle a déjà du succès c'est pas un
sirop qui qui est trop épais qui est
trop indigest c'est très très limpide et
CIT d'utre S pour des bonbons ça paraît
sain pour une fois et puis c'est fait
par des enfants alors c'est quand même
c'est quand même sympa découvrir visiter
et apprendre aussi pendant de jours les
chalents pourront faire leur marché et
demander conseil au jardinier du château
une véritable auè je crois que c'est des
légumes récoltés ici et qui mettent à
disposition et on donne ce qu'on veut
vous en pensez quoi ben que c'est très
bien mon seul problème c'est de savoir
si c'est VI ou pas bio alors c'est oui n
POS un petit peu de question donc déjà
un petit peu question sur le jardin sur
la façon de faire des légumes des fruits
et après bah il nous pose des questions
sou comment on cuisine un petit peu les
poons petit marron les spagetti le
rendez-vous est convivial et le weekend
est annoncé enoleillé de quoi faire
venir de nombreux visiteurs l'an passé
4000 avaiit fait le
déplacement